it's another decision families will need
to chew over around the christmas table
vulnerable children between 5 to 11
years old will be offered a covert 19
vaccine leon has two children under 11.
he agrees those most at risk of the
virus should be protected but would hold
off from rushing to put jabs in all
their arms i think it's important for
them to be exposed to this had it been
something a bit more
menacing i think where the mortality
rate was much greater then i think would
make more sense but as we're you know
moving through this pandemic we're
learning more and i think it's important
to to recognize that our views at the
beginning of this are actually going to
be different and that's how science
works the pfizer vaccine has been
approved for all children aged five and
over but some 330 000 deemed vulnerable
will be the first to get it a relief for
some problems
we automatically knuckle out our babies
when they're born and we've done so for
absolute years and we know it's safe to
do so this is just to start off
something else that will generations it
won't be a big thing the dose would be
smaller around a third of the amount
given to an adult the scientist's
decision follows careful consideration
most children
and certainly all those in the trial
the side effects they experienced were
very mild indeed parents should be
reassured
that jcvi have looked at this data very
carefully the uk's medicines regulator
looks at the data and decides if a
product is safe and in this case they've
said that it is but it's down to the
government's advisors on vaccinations on
who should get it and their consensus at
the moment is that healthy five to
eleven year olds shouldn't get it just
yet
but some are questioning the hesitancy
to go further it's quite clear that the
virus is spreading between children of
primary school age quite a lot and
there's the risk of them spreading it up
to parents at home and to their teachers
my feeling is given the way things are
going that the evidence of benefit
over risk is leaning far and far more
and more towards benefit with the focus
on the booster programme there is no
rush for the children's rollout it's now
a choice many parents will need to make
whilst others without the offer face a
longer weight asha harinag sky news